[Música]
salud en directo América de Francia 24
más Romero sala ya con nosotros en el
estudio mar y vamos a pasar a hablar de
los bebés Porque un estudio habla que el
desarrollo de los infantes durante la
pandemia de Kobe 19 está como rara la
cosa No sí especialmente como en el
período de las primeras cuarentenas de
la época más dura de la pandemia que
pues tiene ese primer año de vida de
estos bebés que participaron en el
estudio no Aunque digamos Es raro pero
no tanto es bastante tranquilizador el
reporte Cuáles son las principales
conclusiones pues para empezar que sí
hay un riesgo levemente mayor de
discapacidad en el neurodesarrollo en
términos de comunicación entre los bebés
nacidos en la pandemia no pero como
vemos es de un 7% únicamente en los
bebés expuestos al virus del cómic 19
durante el período de gestación es decir
que la persona gestante se contagió de
covid mientras estaba embarazada una
leve también en riesgo Pues eso
levemente mayor en términos de
desarrollo en las capacidades de
motricidad fina que es como el manejo de
las manos de empezar a objetos
pequeños en los bebés no es un estudio
publicado en llama Network recientemente
y lo que haces agrupar muchos datos de
muchos estudios es un metaanálisis como
se dice en total esto recoge datos de
más de 21.000 niños durante su primer
año de vida y son muy enfáticos de nuevo
en que este riesgo es muy leve y en que
son los dos únicos ámbitos en los que
han notado algún tipo de diferencia
respecto a bebés que crecieron se
desarrollaron antes exactamente sabemos
y es tomar digamos se va a mantener a
largo plazo por eso era mi duda al
principio claro y es una duda que
compartes tú con los actores del estudio
también de hecho lo señalaban en el
mismo escrito escuchemos le
claramente a pesar de que nuestras
observaciones muestran preocupaciones
potenciales en el desarrollo temprano de
los niños nacidos durante la pandemia de
Kobe 19 se necesita un seguimiento a
largo plazo para ver si esto Se confirma
durante la primera infancia o si existe
una nivelación después del primer año de
vida que destacan también las voces
externas del estudio que hemos leído en
algunos artículos y también en Science
media Center de España no Primero que
hay trastornos del neurodesarrollo que
no se van a ver hasta bastante con
bastante más tiempo de estudio no por
ejemplo los trastornos de aprendizaje No
empiezan a detectarse hasta los siete u
ocho años de edad por ejemplo también
con el autismo las primeras señales
llegan alrededor de los dos años
entonces pues surge la necesidad de
seguir estudiando esto a medida que vaya
pasando el tiempo para entender si
realmente estos efectos son a largo
plazo se van a nivelar Pues con el
tiempo Pero de entrada también lo que
hemos leído es que en general los
expertos parecen relativamente
tranquilizados no por ejemplo con que la
persona complicada que sea gestante no
termine teniendo esa consecuencias en el
bebé y en su neurodesarrollo o también
sino que más bien pues parece que la
conclusión general que se puede extraer
es que el problema viene al final dado
por el contexto de aislamiento el
contexto de cuarentenas también el
contexto Pues de estrés de los padres
durante unos momentos tan difíciles como
fue el inicio de la pandemia de Kobe 19
Pero esto es algo que es más fácil
digamos de nivelar con el tiempo bueno
mar y cambiamos ahora de tema porque hay
un brote de cólera en Líbano Si ayer
llegaron las primeras vacunas de hecho
contra el cólera es una donación del
gobierno francés al Líbano de 13.000
dosis contra esta enfermedad contra el
brote que ahora vamos a desarrollar
escuchemos primero la ministra a la
embajadora francesa
querido ministro La donación que le
estoy hoy de parte de mi país Francia es
una ayuda humanitaria de emergencia en
respuesta a la petición de nuestro país
amigo Líbano pero no es suficiente
los orígenes de esta epidemia que ponen
riesgo la salud pública debe ser
enfrentada por los libaneses esta
epidemia repito es una muestra nueva y
preocupante del declive crítico en el
acceso a la salud y a los servicios e
higiene en Líbano
escuchamos Raúl que son unas palabras
relativamente duras No como con un
cierto reproche al gobierno libanés y es
en la misma línea que el gobierno de
macrón lleva Pues eso como castigando o
recordándole al gobierno libanés que
tiene que desbloquear su situación
política para poder también atender a
los libaneses sin embargo pues
pertinente recordar que Francia es la ex
el ex poder colonial digamos frente al
Líbano y que en sus criticada hay poca
revisión de la responsabilidades
históricas que implicó eso Cuál es la
situación de este brote actualmente mar
y Vamos a repasar las cifras de brote
lleva un mes en el desarrollo y está un
poco preocupante desde que se detectó se
han registrado
1.447 casos y 17 muertes además se trata
del primer brote de cólera que hay en el
país desde 1993 no hace 30 años que el
país estaba sin cólera se cree que
además este origen se desarrolló en
Siria y que pues a través de los países
vecinos también del flujo de refugiados
llegó al Líbano y además ahora ya se
encuentra afectando la misma capital
beirut lo que puede hacer que se
propague también más rápidamente está
siendo además especialmente difícil para
los niños casi la mitad de los casos son
en menores de 15 años algo que pues nos
cuenta Eso no lo que va a ser realmente
difícil para estas poblaciones también
para la supervivientes pues seguir
adelante y además para terminar
recordemos como decíamos hace unos días
que el cólera se trata de una enfermedad
de la pobreza aparece estos lugares
donde no hay recursos aparecen en
nuestro lugares donde no hay medidas de
higiene entonces pues se requiere una
acción urgente para parar este brote en
estas comunidades más vulnerables mar
como siempre Muchísimas gracias por toda
la información de salud y claro que sí
mañana con más mañana con